huh for for copyright I so would have
sang hungry like the wolf to open this
Oh
[Applause]
I say that I don't know if I actually
would have but it's not an option anyway
so who cares hey everybody it is time
for overdue Doctor Who review and I have
arrived at Cold War I feel like this one
doesn't get acknowledged a great deal
and I'm not entirely sure why I think
it's actually pretty solid it's not
amazing but it's well put together it's
got a very strong supporting cast it's
got a mostly successful update of a
classic Doctor Who villain the setting
works the performances are solid across
the board yeah it's pretty good it's not
top-tier I can't imagine anyone putting
this in their favorite episodes ever
list but it's good solid work it's the
kind of thing that you would want to be
good
not every episode can blow you away
that's not gonna happen but when you
have an episode that doesn't you still
want it to be a good solid piece of work
which this is so I feel like this is
just kind of the epitome of a well-made
mid-tier Doctor Who story so I mean I
think the setting is I'm just kind of
surprised that it took knew who this
long to stick them on the summary a
submarines a great confined setting
really just for any kind of story where
you want tension one could argue anytime
that the doctor is on a spaceship that
is isolated that's kind of like a
submarine but I don't know the context
of having it be a Soviet sub in the
added context of the Cold War I don't
know it it feels nice I like it plus you
know very cool supporting cast we got
liam Cunningham and we've got David
Warner and David Warner who is so
regularly a villain just being this
laid-back guy who likes American pop
music that was great loved that so I
enjoyed the setting and I enjoy these
characters and we've got the Ice
Warriors now the Ice Warriors were an
interesting one to even try and bring
back because
the design is so antiquated that it's
really hard to bring that up to date
because when you look at classic Who
monsters introduced back in that era the
Daleks that was a lightning strike they
were so bizarre that you could just
leave them alone
the Cybermen had to be updated ret or
rather regularly and then you've got
then you've got things like the ice wars
which feel honestly a bit like the Yeti
like it worked then I'm not sure that
would work now they give it the old
college try though
I like how most of the emphasis on the
redesign is just sort of streamlining
and and making the armor look more like
armor but keeping it true to that
original design right down to the fact
that the opening for the mouth doesn't
quite line up with the mouth and you
really only see the bottom part right
there like I don't know if that was
intentional I assume it was and I
thought that was kind of neat I also
like the emphasis of the idea of it
leaving its armor the execution of that
I'll come back to but as a concept very
cool especially because it basically
means that you don't have to update the
armor that much and it gives you more
leeway to update the creature itself
especially considering we never saw them
outside the armor prior to that so
conceptually totally on board with that
I get it it's cool as far as the whole
thing of it being a cold war story it's
it works for the functions of this it's
a little odd because you can go back to
classic ooh and there were lots of
stories that were functionally cold war
stories that were allegorically cold war
stories but that also would have made
them topical for the time whereas now
the Cold War is history and for a decent
chunk of the viewership of the show or
even my own subscriber base it was over
before they were born so as far as
they're concerned it's ancient history
so it it's a little bit of an odd thing
but it still works as a setting I think
for the most part the here's the thing
about taking skaldak out of the armor
like I said conceptually I'm down with
it I think they made a mistake at the
very end
having the helmet come back and giving
us a real good look at it because then
we're at the mercy of TV budget cgi
which just is what it is and it's not
great and it's kind of frustrating
because I think they were very smart
prior to that point having practical
effect hands that were maybe a little
bit too spindly but cool they were there
they were a real thing and using smoke
and steam to obscure the face like you
could see teeth you could see eyes but
we didn't get a good look at him and
that I thought was a clever move so I
don't know why they then undercut it by
giving us a really good look at this CGI
lizard head I don't know why they did
that
apples unnecessary Oh like and I nobody
ever talks about this but like skaldak
brings up that he taught his daughter
the ways of wars like look the Ice
Warriors have always been dominated by
male characters this is a complete sgw
agenda they're just cooking the I swear
I'm sorry I couldn't resist I don't know
why I felt they need to do that but it
occurred to me as I was watching it just
that thought process which I'm not
trying to actually parody anybody
specific I don't think anybody's ever
made that claim about the Ice Warriors
although with my luck someone in the
comments is gonna link me to a video
where somebody actually does do that if
it exists please don't tell me let me
believe that it doesn't over all this
this is actually an episode that's hard
to find a lot to talk about because it
is just solid it's good solid nuts and
bolts storytelling it is a little bit
weird coming off the back of rings of
Akutan that they pivot on a song coz
though obviously rings of Akutan did it
was a major
thing in it whereas here it's just a
recurring thing and it sort of pivots on
the singing that well it gets brought up
the idea of scale like Todd his daughter
the songs of the red snow I think it was
and then you know car eventually very
nervously singing hungry like the wolf
like two episodes in a row we're good
we're gonna kind of pivot on singing I
I'm not sure there's really a reason for
that
I don't think that's a through well
we'll see I'm gonna keep an eye out for
it now but yeah I don't think that's
something that keeps going so it's kind
of odd to have a crop up two episodes in
a row it is just nice to see a really
strong supporting cast
I like the strength of Lee liam
Cunningham captain and watching him
stand up to the doctor and the ways that
he does is very rewarding and ditto with
David Warner like I said that's just fun
the fact that this guy who's almost
always a villain is just this a and who
has actually been a villain in Doctor
Who big finish some of which I've heard
him doing so it's nice to see him kick
back and be a little bit light a little
bit goofy that's kind of neat and also
in addition to obviously the guy who
plays Davos liam Cunningham there's
another actor from Game of Thrones in
here as well he was like he was the one
who's I think supposed to be married off
in the red wedding before everything
went day yeah it's been a long time but
he's here as well playing sort of your
standard buttoned up to tightly wound
jerk of a second officer bit of a stock
character but for the purposes of a
single episode of television sure that
works well enough I did I did kind of
like the acknowledgement that oh the Ice
Warriors are actually still around
because they pick up skaldak at the end
because up to this point and actually
even after this with Empress of Mars
there's very much an implication that
they're done that their time is done and
they're finished so while I kind of like
that it you know we got to see us a ship
of theirs and they took him back and I
am left thinking that that feels like a
fluke because everything else is has
really been a heavy indication that
their time is is largely over especially
a modern who they seem to bang that drum
quite a bit I don't know what their
timeline is as far as like the the years
that the classic episodes that they turn
up and are supposed to take place I
should have looked into that but that's
research I don't do that I suppose the
only other thing that is worth noting
because I don't love it is that the
resolution is basically resolution by
happy luck by good coincidence because
while the doctor and Clara talking down
skaldak is enough to stall him
ultimately it isn't until his own people
show up that he truly stops and that
bugs me because well that's just lucky
timing thank God they showed up when
they did because otherwise we didn't
have a way to win and it it it's not
quite to the level where I'm gonna call
it deus ex machina they certainly set it
up that he called them and he wasn't
expecting an answer that was part of why
he had gone nihilistic it was prevented
to blow everybody up so like I get it
it's and it's kind of set up but it is a
little bit like yeah yeah lucky lucky
they showed up when they did boy howdy
and it's it's yeah this is a little bit
a little bit contrite or contrived or
something I don't want to go supposed to
call it lazy writing cuz it's not a that
level but it is a little bit like
basically they hit all the heroes did
was stall but they also didn't know that
this thing was going to come and save
them so they were stalling but didn't
know they were stalling and it just
wasn't where I don't know it's it's
still perfectly fine episode I was happy
to rewatch it I won't feel the urge to
watch it again anytime soon though at
the same time but
it's a step up from rings of Akutan you
get the bad if nothing else so that is
cold war Yuri watched it lately would
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it bunch of
stuff to do like subscribe I have a
patreon all that stuff click on the
things or don't end of the day you're
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
that insane
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]